Okay, so I've got some title ideas
for the next Spiderman film.
That's great! Can't wait to hear 'em.
Well, you know how every one features some play on the word "home"? I think these are gonna be right on brand
Well, then go on! Let's hear 'em!
Picture this. Spiderman: Home Wrecker.
Where Peter cheats on M.J. Mmm? :o
Hoh, wow. Well that's upsetting because they just got together. And they're not married. And they don't have a home  -_-
I hear ya loud and clear. How about this?
Spiderman: Homebound
Peter Parker develops terrible agoraphobia
Pretty hard to fight crime when you won't leave the house
People know who he is now.
Maybe it makes him nervous.
Well, I guess that makes sense. What else were you thinking?
How about this one then?
Spiderman: Home on the Range
It's a Western, gunslinger meets webslinger
Ooh, dangerous and sticky, I like it
Alright. Well, how about you try this one on for size?
Spiderman: Home Alone
Where instead of using his fighter powers, he instead sets creative traps using everyday household objects
Eat paint can, Hobgoblin
Oh, and then finally we have one that I know you're gonna love
Spiderman: Home for the Holidays
A nondenominational celebration for the entire family.
Well, I'm sold. Call up the boys. We've got ourselves something to announce at Comic Con.
[Film Theory - Marvel Theme]
Hello Internet
Welcome to Film Theory
Using our theorist tingle to dispel all of Mysterio's illusions and let me tell ya,
Between fake restaurants, fake Mysterios and fake Nick Fury's, I was tingling all over the place
while I was watching Far From Home. Probably should get that one checked out by a doctor, but seriously,
I felt like I couldn't trust anything.
The ushers were in there trying to pry me out of my seat,
And I'm like "NO! I feel the barf drones around me.
You're all just trying to make me think the movie's over, but we're still somewhere in Act 2!"
Long story short, I'm not allowed in that theater again.
On the plus side, I left Far From Home with a heck of a lot of theory fodder. So today I'm tackling a theory that is so speculative,
It's more hypothesis than theory. I know, I know,
Blasphemy. But coming out of the theater,
I couldn't get it out of my head and I thought it was a cool topic to talk about on the series.
You see, the most important part of Far From Home isn't so much what's in the movie.
It's instead what's coming after the movie.
Far From Home isn't just another step in Marvel's stairway to box-office heaven.
It's clear that this movie is acting as an inflection point, between where we've been and where we're going.
A gateway to the Post-Endgame era of Marvel,
Where everything is suddenly being called into question. From your leadership to your very identity.
And as a part of that I'm here today to predict
Spiderman's next major role in all of it.
Because at this point, the Tom Holland's Spiderman movies have tipped their hand just a bit too far.
I think they've revealed just a wee bit too much.
And as a result,
I have a solid hypothesis as to where things are headed for the old webhead in the next feature film.
So book your tickets now, ladies and gentlemen,
Because Spiderman's next opponent will be a massive showdown,
With the Sinister 6.
For those of you who might not be familiar,
The Sinister 6 is a team consisting of a number of Spiderman's nastiest villains.
Can you guess how many?
Usually a massive team-up of super villains would be something that would develop pretty late into a comic's career,
As they figured out how to come up with exciting new storylines for the same character,
But when it comes to the Sinister 6,
Their beginnings actually start as far back as the beginning of Spiderman comics themselves, back in 1963. :o
And since that time there have been no less than 24 different versions.
Which have had names like The Sinister 6,
The Sinister 7, The Sinister 12,
The Superior 6, The Hexagon of Haters,
The Six Most Sinister, and the 6 Men of Sinestry.
That hexagon one was a joke by the way, but it's not like you could tell, right?
This group's gone through more reboots than the Spiderman movies have. But in all seriousness,
Me standing here as my virtual cutout saying that the films are gonna feature Spiderman's most iconic villain group,
Probably isn't gonna be settin' the world on fire.
So instead, let's get even more specific by picking out who exactly those six characters are gonna be.
That would be a little bit more impressive, right?
I mean, I need to do a lot of making up for past failed prediction theories.
So nailing the 6 major villains for Peter P's next outing in a movie that hasn't even been announced yet would be tight.
Over the course of Marvel history there have been over
40 members of the Sinister 6, which leaves us with a lot of villain options to slot into the group.
It's like the popular frat of the comics. Everyone's rushing to get in. Luckily, I don't need to rely on my usual prediction methods.
There have been plenty of solid hints sprinkled throughout the series.
If we rewind back to Homecoming, by the end of that film,
We've already met 50% of the crew who will be heading up this new version of the Sinister 6.
The first and most obvious inclusion is Adrian Toomes, aka The Vulture.
Who may have been kind enough to preserve Spidey's secret identity in prison.
"If I knew who he was, he'd already be dead."
But now that the whole world knows the truth, all bets are off. Toomes has got himself an axe to grind.
It's also worth noting that The Vulture is an OG member of The Sinister 6.
The original seven iterations of this group, all featured The Vulture prominently,
So not including him when he's already an established part of this Cinematic Universe would be a big surprise.
And that's not all. In Vulture's crew, we have ourselves a brief passing reference to yet another classic Spiderman villain.
The Shocker. In the MCU, Shocker isn't much of a supervillain,
but instead he's just a sucky salesman who fires off Vulture's illegal rockets in public and attracts the attention of Spiderman,
Which in turn, makes Vulture realize that old Sparky is too much of a liability, and needs to be let go in the most violent way possible.
While initially, it looks like The Vulture's just turned the Sinister 6 into the Fearsome 5,
He quickly replaces Shocker with a new Shocker,
quite explicitly passing the torch.
"Here. Now you're The Shocker."
I don't think that's just a throwaway line there, friends.
It's brief and it's one that's easy to write off as just a tongue-in-cheek Easter Egg,
But remember, we saw a similar series of events become the major plot twist in Far From Home.
We're a bunch of smaller characters that have been set up via past movies, suddenly emerged to the forefront to become major players.
So The Shocker having a similar reveal in the third spider-man movie?
Oh yeah. It is definitely precedented. And not only that, but Shocker is indeed a canonical member of the Sinister 6 in the comics.
I mean, practically everyone is, but still, he's there. Usually as a member of the expanded Sinisters, like the Sinister 7 and the Sinister 66.
You heard that right, SIXTY-SIX.
Here, I thought Infinity War had a lot of characters.
So anyway, that is two villains right there in the first movie,
But we can keep going. There are a couple other tertiary villains that we see running in Vulture's crew,
But I'm more hesitant to count on these guys because they rarely appear in the Sinister 6,
And they just don't have the same level of name appeal.
Specifically,
I'm referring to the Prowler, played in Homecoming by the Childish Gambino himself, Donald Glover,
And The Tinkerer who is worth mention because, well if I didn't you guys would light me up in the comments thinking I missed him.
I didn't. He just isn't interesting enough to make the official counted squad here.
Which, then of course brings us to the end of Homecoming.
Here, The Vulture goes to prison and meets Mac Gargan. If that name doesn't ring a bell, the tattoo on his neck certainly should.
A scorpion. Looks like Mac is carrying on the grand tradition of arthropods in this franchise by taking the role of The Scorpion.
A guy who traditionally has a giant tail that shoots acid.
How the more technology centric films will make this attack strategy less awkward, is up for debate.
But there's no doubt that he's gonna be joining forces with Toomes. In just his brief scene alone,
It's immediately established that he's also after Spiderman, and wants to team up.
So to recap, at the start of Far From Home,
We know that both these baddies are still in prison together, and the new Shocker is still floating around out there somewhere too.
Giving us a solid lead on at least 3 out of 6 Sinisters.
Let's see who else is gonna surface in Far From Home. In the beginning of the new movie, Peter and his friends just got themselves blipped out of existence for 5 years by Thanos.
The very fabric of reality has been shaken. Whoopsy!
But no worries.
The Avengers figured out that pesky time-travel business, and now everything is back to normal.
With everyone now completely acclimated to aliens and magic and Tony Stark destroying huge sections of major cities,
It turns out to be the perfect place for Mysterio to enter the fray, with the world willing to believe literally anything at this point.
Literally anything at this point waiting back in his organization of background players from all the past movies decide to create their own
superhero a soldier from another universe Mysterio and if there was ever a
Superhero slash villain perfect for the internet age. This guy is it he's fake
He only does things for the cloud his entire reputation
Depends on everything being on video because if there was indeed a true Avengers level threat Mysterio would just be flat-out useless in short
Mysterio would just make a great youtuber that would be funny if it wasn't completely depressing
Anyway Hauk Mysterio up is another core member of our new Sisterhood of the Traveling Sinister's now
I know the first thing you're gonna say, but we saw Mysterio die at the end of far from home
Which yes is absolutely true. I totally think Quentin Beck is dead
Despite my best efforts in researching for this episode to prove otherwise
but and far from home where very clearly shown a shot of his team taking the computers and drives that retain all of
Mysterio's files, I mean think about it
They were pulling the Mysterio shtick before they got control of Edith Edith
Just enabled him to do it at a bigger scale and throughout the movie
They very intentionally show Quentin Beck and Mysterio separately
Mysterio is just a projection a drone of what this superhero suit looks like
So not only can Mysterio come back that sort of plotline is also canon in the source
material Mysterio's original plot in the early days of the spider-man comics starting back in issue 13 is
Pretending to be a good guy exposing spider-man's true identity to Jay jonah Jameson and then faking his own death
Which wouldn't you know?
It all happened to be the key beats. We see him do and far from home
So we should consider staying true to his comic book origins
and remember that he was also an
OG alum of the sinister six taking part in the first five iterations of the group taking a break for 6 & 7 and then
coming back strong in 8 & 10 meaning that
Mysterio is taking up our slot number 4
Now from here our job gets a little harder because we have to get two villains that we haven't
Directly seen yet, but ones that I think the movies are definitely setting us up for the first open slot
I think we'll take advantage of Marvel's newest playthings
The scrawls Captain Marvel was keen on showing off the scrolls and how well they're able to infiltrate the ranks of normal humans
But it was odd to see them also show up and far from home a story. They seem pretty
Disconnected from why would Marvel be showing us this now at this point in the movies?
well
I think it boils down to two reasons both of which go back to that inflection point I was talking about at the beginning of
The episode first, they know that spider-man is and will always be their biggest hero
He's Marvel's equivalent of Batman
I mean sure Iron Man was big for the movies but spider-man is just iconic
He was big before the Marvel Cinematic Universe. He was big before Ironman really changed the superhero scene
So if the Skrulls are gonna play a big role in the future of the MCU
They need to be introduced to mainstream audiences who may not have seen Captain Marvel through a more mainstream
movie a Spider Man
So there's your reason one, but there is a second and more relevant reason that applies to our theory today
You see there just so happens to be a Spider Man villain with a very scroll like power set the chameleon. He's a shapeshifter
Who's able to disguise himself behind the face of whoever he wants?
in fact
The chameleon was Spider Man's first ever villain introduced in spider-man number one way back in
1963 and barring some fan theories
He's never actually appeared on the big screen before which leaves the pathway totally open to bringing him in via
Shapeshifters that we already know exist in this universe the scrolls
So all you would need to slot him into the Sinister's is a scroll gone rogue one with a chip on their scaly green
Shoulder, that's not just speculation
we may already have him identified many fans believe they've already
Spotted this guy in the MCU right here the guard who sent to surveil Peter while he's in Europe
It's a small detail. But his name is Dimitri and wouldn't you know it but that exact name Dimitri?
Smear to Cobb is the exact identity of the chameleon in the comics give this man a pledge pin
ladies and gentlemen
He is our number 5 which leaves us with one last slot to fill and honestly if you go in any number of really cool
Directions when it comes to the spider-man movies thus far the MCU has had a habit of tricking us
They know we know these stories and characters
That's what happens when a hero gets rebooted
So frequently in such a short amount of time
So to keep us off-balance there to borrow a phrase from the show that must not be named subverting expectations
they're reinventing or
Reimagining the good and bad guys in ways that we don't expect to keep everything fresh and new Aunt May is an old
MJ doesn't stand for Mary Jane and Peter's biggest bully flash isn't a typical jock
He's just an even bigger nerd in much the same way there are villains creeping around here that we may not even see coming for
Example you remember one of Peters relatively unmemorable teachers back in homecoming. Well her name mrs
Warren which could be a name picked totally at random or it could be that she's a reimagined version of
miles Warren Peters biology professor starting in spider-man
148 who ends up becoming one of the sinister six villains The Jackal a villain mind you who goes on to clone Peter his dead
Girlfriend and his dead parents in a plot line that wasn't super well-received by comic fans
But still she's there and waiting to be swiped right on so go ahead sinister, six take a chance
It's also been pointed out by others that spider-man's been seen battling the Manfredi crime family leading us to believe that the comic book villains
Silvermane who's associated with that family in the comics may also be floating around along with a whole slew of his accomplices
There are plenty of other Easter eggs like these and they might materialize down the line, but here's the thing
None of these guys are cutting the mustard for me up until now
everyone we've talked about we've either seen before like the stereo or vulture or is just a backup player like shocker or
Chameleon, we need a big name. We need a major player. The sinister six needs its new lead singer, its headliner
We need ourselves either Doc Ock or more likely the Green Goblin and of the two
I think the Green Goblin is all set up and ready to roll out
Not only is the Green Goblin one of the most frequent members of the sinister six
But because the Goblin is usually a member of the Osborn family who are tech billionaires just like Tony Stark
They tend to have ties to most of the other villains in the comics and likewise in the new cinematic universe where technology is
fueling a lot of these characters powers
They would have connections in that realm to the Osborn technology would help supplement what the vulture is doing the Osborn technology would help supplement
The Mysterio gang the Osborn technology would help make the shocker stronger, but now let's go back to something
I said earlier about subverting expectations
Remember flash the nerd bully. He is very clearly being set up for a future plotline throughout the movie
There's this ongoing
thread about his
relationship with his
Parents a weird text message thread with them and that one scene when they return home and he's met by their driver in both scenes
Flash is being ignored by his parents. They're absent they've forgotten about him
it's also clear that they have a very formal relationship with flash having to call them father and
It's very similar to the way that Harry Osborn reacts with his father Norman Osborn and most other spider-man stories
Including the Sam Raimi movies theater, man
Traditional father Norman Osborn Flash's family is also very rich as my dad's car says just like The Osbournes
Heck it's even been suggested that those super-rich Osborne's are busy building oscorp's new headquarters in the old avengers building which you can see being
Constructed in far from home, but I know what you're thinking. He's Flash Thompson. He's not in Osborn and you know what?
That's just what I thought too
That's what literally every fan wiki online says but it seems like literally
Everyone has been jumping to conclusions here because at no point in the movies do we ever hear?
Flash's last name he is never once called Flash Thompson
Not once he'd is always only flesh
Man, even right here in the credits. He's only
Listed as Flash Matt
seriously
You might wanna that right?
there is our smoking gun loyal theorists the big twist the way our
expectations are gonna end up being subverted in the next spider-man movie is that Flash's last name is gonna be revealed as
Osborn that's what I'm building up a good flow here you're throwing off my dramatic reveal
Well, here's a more dramatic reveal for you. Oh
Yeah, so it's not in the script or the credits
But yeah, well, why didn't you tell me earlier because even if he is Flash Thompson?
there's a very real chance that he could have been just
adopted by the Osbourne's that sort of angle would have
support from the comics in the story
Norman Osborn takes flash under his wing gives flash a job makes him feel like part of the family and ultimately
Turns him against spider-man who he was formerly. Idolizing just like we see flash
Idolizing spider-man in far from home. So there you have it friends
We got ourselves our six villains vulture shocker
Scorpion chameleon Mysterio and Green Goblin all set and ready to go but to close things out here
I think I'll put myself even further out on a limb
I think it's worth pointing out that there's one villain in this group who is different than all the others
Vulture vulture is very clearly established to be a family man
I built this whole place because I got people like to look at he's not about world domination or being a renowned superhero
Heck he doesn't even want to attract the attention of the Avengers
If you bring damage control party Avengers down here with he's not in it for the cloud like Mysterio
He's not in it for revenge
He's only in it to take care of his wife and his daughter
the same daughter who's spider-man saved at the end of homecoming and who then went on to rescue vulture himself during the final battle we
Already know that vulture wouldn't give up Peter Parker's identity to scorpion and we know he has at least half a dozen
opportunities to finish him off during that final confrontation and doesn't so when faced with
Option of teaming up alongside a bunch of villains who are bent on world domination
Well, he might initially go along for the ride. It's my prediction that vulture will instead defect to instead protect
Someone who shares his values and goals someone who still appreciates helping out the little guy the local neighborhood in the end
Vulture is gonna be the one to end up protecting
Spider-man against the rest of the sinister six. Anyway that is more than enough speculation and fan fiction for the day
I mean, I'm already trying to make calls on a movie that hasn't even been announced to exist yet
Let me slow my roll a little here regardless of how it all plays out. I'm excited for this third installment in spider-man franchise
I actually love these movies. They're some of my favorite in the MCU and whether you agree or not
I hope you like watching and theorizing about where things go next because it's a superhero movie. It's all just for fun
Just like this is all just a theory ah film
theory and if you want to see more spider-man content check out this video on the left where I analyze the physics of
Spider-man's deadly web slinging. It turns out that spider-man should have died multiple times over
Regardless of this super strike or while you're here. Make sure you click the button on the right to subscribe
I've got an upcoming theory on which spider-man would win in a battle royale of
Spider-man make your predictions now friends that theories coming up in the near future and with that I'm off next week
Let's take a break from superheroes. Shall we?